wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
jetzt mal ehrlich kippe wie soll ich
dich dann ernst nehmen wenn du da und
deine meinung ist ja ich weiß ich habe
sie vor ein paar tagen gesagt dass ich
die keine neue website machen kann aber
ich habe nachgedacht und du hast recht
familie ist das wichtigste und du wirst
meiner familie deswegen möchte ich dir
hh soll das jetzt heißen dass du doch
eine website für mich machst ja also
natürlich müssen wir noch über den preis
sprechen aber ich mache dir da ein
faires angebot und familien fair
sozusagen
nein nein ich meine nein das geschäft
mit max und tarik ist geplatzt
deshalb kannst du jetzt zu mir oder ich
brauche den auftrag jahre
warum meiner firma geht es schlecht ich
habe finanzielle probleme ich hatte
schulden jahre warum brauche ich die
aufträge du hast kein geld mehr
weißt du was unsere eltern immer sagen
nimm dir beispiel am pepe mach es wie er
beendete sein studium und werde so
erfolgreich wie pepe und du hast kein
geld mehr tut mir leid nicht wo ich habe
gelogen ich wollte dass unsere eltern
stolz auf mich sind
was soll ich denn jetzt machen keine
chance mehr
keine teuren autos keine teuren hotels
das muss alles aufhören
du musst ganz neu anfangen
ich bekomme aber keine neuen aufträge
wenn die leute sehen dass ich kein geld
habe
du kannst meine website mach was draus
ok
[Musik]